let me ask what is war
in saying that war is a prolonged
violent struggle between groups what do
the words prolonged groups and violent
mean
i said at the sort of intersection of
economics and political science and i
i also dwell a little bit in psychology
but that's partly because i'm married to
psychologists sometimes do research with
her
all these things are really different so
if you're a political scientist you
spend a lot of time just classifying a
really narrow kind of conflict
and studying that and that's that's an
important way to make progress
as a social scientist but i'm not trying
to make progress i'm trying to sort of
help everybody step back and say you
know what there's like some common
things that we know
from these disciplines
that uh relate to a really wide range
phenomenon basically we we can talk
about them in a very similar way and we
get really similar insights so i wanted
to
actually
bring them together but i still had to
like say let's hold out individual
violence which has a lot in common but
but individuals
choose to engage in violence for
more and sometimes different reasons so
let's just put that aside
so that we can focus a bit
and let's really put aside short
incidents of violence because those
might have the same kind of
things explaining them but actually
there's a lot of other things that can
explain short violence short violence
can be really
uh demonstrative like you can just i can
use it to communicate information
the thing that all of it has in common
is that it doesn't generally make sense
it's not your best option most of the
time
and so i wanted to say let's take this
thing that should be puzzling we kind of
think it's normal we kind of think this
is what all humans do
uh but let's point out that it's not
normal
and then figure out why and let's talk
about why and so that's so i was trying
to throw out the the short violence i
was trying to throw out the individual
violence i was also trying to throw out
all the
competition that happens that's not
violent that's that's the normal normal
competition i was trying to say let's
talk about violent competition because
that's kind of the puzzle
so that's really interesting you said
usually
people try to find a narrow definition
and you said progress so you make
progress by
finding a narrow definition for example
of military conflict
in a particular context yeah and
progress means all right well how do we
prevent this particular kind of military
conflict or maybe if it's already
happening how do we de-escalate it and
how do we solve it so from a geopolitics
perspective from an economics
perspective and you're looking for a
definition of war that is as broad as
possible
but
not so broad that you cannot achieve a
deep level of understanding
of
why it happens and how it can be avoided
right and a comment basically like
recognize that common principles govern
some kinds of behavior that look
pretty different like an indian
ethnic riot
is obviously pretty different than
invading a neighboring country right but
uh and that's pretty different than two
villages or two gangs a lot of what i
work on is studying organized criminals
and gangs two gangs going to where you
think is really different and and of
course it is but
but there are some like common
principles you can just think about
conflict and the use of violence and um
not learn everything but just get a lot
just get really really far by sort of
seeing the commonalities rather than
just focusing on the differences so
again those words are prolonged groups
and violent can you maybe linger on each
of those words what does prolong mean
what's where's the line between short
and long what does groups mean
and what does violet mean so let me you
know i have a friend who um
someone has become a friend through the
process of my work and and writing this
book also uh who was
20 30 years ago was a was gang leader in
chicago
um so this guy named napoleon english or
nap
and i remember one time he was saying
well you know when i was young i used to
i was just 15 16 and he'd go to the
neighboring gang's territory he says i'd
go gang banging and i said well i didn't
know what that meant i said what does
that mean and he said oh that just meant
i'd shoot him up like i'd shoot at
buildings
i might shoot at people
i wasn't trying to kill that he wasn't
trying to kill them he was just trying
to sort of
send a signal that he was a tough guy
and he was fearless and he was someone
who they should be careful with
and so i didn't want to call that war
right that was
that was
that's something different that was it
was short it was kind of sporadic
and and he wasn't
and he was he was basically trying to
send them information and this is what
countries do all the time right we have
military parades
uh and we uh we might have border
skirmishes
and uh and and i wanted to sort of so is
it what's short is is it three-month
border skirmish a war i mean i don't i
don't try to get into those things i
don't want to but i want to point out
that like
these long grueling months and years of
violence are like or the problem in the
puzzle
and i just i didn't want to spend a lot
of time talking about
um
the
international version of gang banging
it's a different phenomenon so what is
it about napoleon that doesn't
nap let's call him
not to add confusion yeah that doesn't
qualify for war is it the individual
aspect
is it that violence is not
the
thing that is sought but the um
communication of information is what is
sought
or is it the shortness of it
is it all of those com
it's a little bit i mean he was the head
of a group we were always becoming the
head of a group at that point
um
and that group eventually did go to war
with those neighboring gangs which is to
say it was just long drawn out conflict
over months and months and months
but
i think one of the big insights from my
fields
is that
you know you're constantly negotiating
over something
right whether you're officially
negotiating or you're all posturing like
you're kind of you're bargaining over
something
and uh you should be able to
figure out a way to split that pie and
you could use violence
but violence is everybody's miserable
like if you're nap like if you start a
war one you know there's lots of risks
you could get killed that's not good
uh you could kill somebody else and go
to jail which is what happened to him
that's not good uh your soldiers get
killed no one's buying your drugs in the
middle of a gunfight so it interrupts
your business and so on and on it's like
it's really miserable this is what we're
seeing right now you know as we're
recording you know the
russian invasion of ukraine is now it's
fourth or fifth week
everybody's
if it didn't dawn on them before it's
dawned on them now just how brutal and
costly this is
as you describe for everybody so
everybody is losing in this war yeah i
mean that's maybe the inside everybody
loses something from war
and
there was usually not always but this
the point is there was usually a way to
get
what you wanted or be better off without
having to fight over it so there's this
it's just fighting is just
politics by other means and it's just
inefficient
costly brutal
devastating means and so that's like the
deep insight and so i kind of wanted to
say um so so i guess like what's not war
and i i mean i don't i don't want i
don't try to belabor the definitions
because some some you know there's
reams and reams of political science
papers written on like what's war what's
not all right
people disagree
uh
the
i just wanted to say
war is the thing that we shouldn't be
doing or where's the violence that
doesn't make sense
there's a whole bunch of other violence
including
gang banging and skirmishes and things
that might make sense
uh precisely because they're cheap ways
of communicating or their their way
they're
they're not particularly costly where's
the thing that's just so costly we
should be trying to avoid is maybe like
the meta way i think about it
right uh nevertheless definitions are
interesting so outside of the academic
bickering yeah every time you try to
define something i'm a big fan of it
the process
illuminates so the destination doesn't
matter because the moment you arrive at
the definition
um you lose the power
yeah one of the interesting things i
mean so people you know if you want to
do you know some of what i do is just
quantitative analysis of conflict and
and if you want to do that if you want
to sort of run statistics on word then
you have to code it all up and and then
lots of people have done that there's
four or five major data sets where
people or teams of people have over time
said we're going to code years of war
between these
groups or within a country and what's
interesting is how
difficult these these data sets don't
often agree you have to make all of
these the decision gets really
complicated like when does the war begin
right does it does it begin
when a certain number of people have
been killed did it begin
did it what if there's like lots of
skirmishing and sort of like little
terror attacks or a couple bombs lobbed
and then eventually turns into war do we
do we call that did do we back date it
to like when the first act of violence
started and then what do we do with all
the one the times when there was like
that low scale low intensity violence or
lob bombs lobbed and
do we do we call those wars but or maybe
only if they eventually get worse like
so you get it actually is really tricky
and the defense on the offensive aspect
so everybody
uh hitler in world war ii
it seems like he never attacked anybody
he's always defending against the unjust
attack of everybody else as he's taking
over the world so that's like
information propaganda that every side
is
trying to communicate to the world so
you can't listen to necessarily
information like self-report data you
have to kind of look past that somehow
maybe look especially in the modern
world as much as possible at the data
how many bombs dropped
how many people killed
how the number of estimates of the
number of troops moved from one location
to another and that kind of thing
you